if you're a new filmmaker that started
making films within the last four to
five years my opinion is slightly [ __ ]
this form is purely created for
filmmakers that want to learn how to
tell a compelling story these they're in
your space for filmmakers that want to
express themselves through beautiful
imagery I'm in no way bashing that with
this film
every single day I'm learning and I'm
collaborating with people these are just
some of the tricks and tips that I've
learnt along the way and if you are one
of those filmmakers that are feeling
slightly [ __ ] well then let me help you
and watch yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
every now and then you get a film that's
so infectious that literally shapes an
entire decade of filmmaking around four
to five years ago an Italian filmmaker
Leonardo Dallas and created a piece of
film called The Watchtower of Turkey
that bent the minds of many creative
people it was the first time so many
seamless transitions hyper lapses and
rapid-fire montages accompanied by an
emotive score where scene work so
beautifully within one Foreman at online
phone this kind of foam is known as the
purple power of zero so uniquely
different to a curious eye that it
literally cannot be replicated the
problem is everyone tried to replicate
it there are even transition packs used
to this day called Turkey transitions
the watchtower effects and then others
disguised beneath different names this
is what started the movement I call the
over-styled lazy idea era
films that just look really pretty with
no substance whatsoever if you want to
stand out one should never develop an
idea for a film based off of a phone
they are however a handful of filmmakers
that have been influenced by this
movement except their content has
progressed beyond just being a bunch of
pretty pictures in a world filled with
pretty pictures they have the most
important part of any phone an idea one
of these filmmakers being Matt krohmer
Matt's work is visually remarkable he
does things with a camera I don't even
understand I am on the other hand a
practical for me and my style is woven
around each narrative I flew him to New
York spend a couple of days with him and
get into the mind of visual storyteller
and along with my skill center scenario
and develop five simple steps on how to
create a film that will be remarkable in
a way that's meaningful to your audience
[Music]
so uncommon okay we have from sunrise to
sunset to come up with some sort of an
idea and film it
okay passed yet one of the most
important parts about developing an idea
is leaving your ego at home rather try
and focus on an idea that's useful
something that's beneficial for people
entertainment is hugely beneficial I
believe that everyone is a product of
their upbringing and current
surroundings therefore we have thousands
of unhatched ideas in online that we
just need to find the right outlet for
that being through looking at art you've
been watching reading a book or just
rambling with a mate okay this part is
clearly re-enacted for you just for me
saying this got you I have an idea
what's that why don't we make a film
about making a phone bro that's a good
idea there's an app called the most
dangerous ride together which is pretty
great for writing a stream of conscious
thought from there I go straight into
research to make sure that what I'm
talking about is correct once you have
that garrison down you need to write a
narrative structure even if it's loose I
use three acts to tell my stories my
three acts work differently to the ones
who know they are impact which is the
reason to watch the phone ride until the
end and three persuasion which is the
climax it's an emotion you should always
leave the audio
[Music]
now that you've written your script you
need to film this thing which isn't so
hard if you've literally written
yourself a to-do list that the
professionals call a shot list this is
super important the reason I always
write a script or shortlist and why'd
super important to stick to idea is
because of a term called location
sickness this is when you go out to
shoot your specific idea but then get
swayed by something that looks pretty or
beautiful and then try and embed it into
your film somehow which at the end of
the day doesn't actually make sense you
have to put your idea first improv
filmmaking is important yes but
sometimes locations can throw you off
because well locations are pretty and we
filmmakers at the end of the day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and then when it comes to production I
almost always have another filmmakers
shooting with this week being Matt
what's up where we knock off every part
of the script together but by but but
most importantly have a laugh filmmaking
is supposed to be fun not snobby art I'm
gonna pass over to Matthew he's like a
wizard with this [ __ ] he's editing his
piece and it would only really make
sense if he spoke about this process one
of the most important aspects of a
well-polished
edit is being able to cut your imagery
in a way that he pokes an emotion from
your viewer a well-crafted visual story
has the ability to activate the
subconscious of your audience's mind and
make them feel a certain way even though
they might not know why just yet I like
to reference the Kuleshov effect a lot
to illustrate this point the idea is
that an expressionless man is shown
first on screen in succession with three
images first being a cup of soup the
second a girl on a coffin and third a
woman what happens when these images are
shown in a deliberate order is that the
viewer will bring their own emotional
reaction to the sequence this then can
influence the audience's perception of
what is actually happening this is the
foundation of cinema but more
specifically editing need to understand
the human mind in such a way that you
can seamlessly connect a visual to a
feeling on command Wow cheese Brut that
was in honey this is the hardest part of
any foam releasing your film to an
audience for them to judge freely it
takes a large level of confidence but it
definitely gets easier with time the
more you start to believe in your own
work but first you need to create a
thumbnail and a title this is all you
really have to get somebody to click on
your film and to watch it maybe ask
yourself this would you click on a pane
looking thumbnail if you had no idea who
the filmmaker was behind the visual how
important is the title of the film to
you is clickbait irritating this is a
question for the audience which I find a
perfect balance with never lying but by
slightly bending the truth in order to
spark some form of interest like now
which is a trick we called lans whacking
where we recording in flares format to
edit with that looks really rad and will
make for really interesting image at
some
they'll be shooting but it's not really
a crucial part of the film so but you
told me is that irritating
[Music]
now comes for the biggest adrenaline
rush clicking the upload button
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed today's video just a
quick update from next week I'm gonna be
speaking about the film with 100
filmmakers from 100 different countries
which is super exciting fun believe the
amount of questions I received that how
many brilliant filmmakers they are also
another update merch we sold out as
merch or missing the first day which is
incredible that was the first generation
brew merge so what we've decided to do
is create another rage so go check that
out I'll put the link in the description
there's Matt berry from Sandia thank you
that was the first time I've
collaborated with another filmmaker like
this I'm probably gonna be doing it a
lot more so for now go check out Matt's
work it's truly awesome as always you're
awesome drew and I'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]